welcome to this video playing Wolverine
from Brazil okay time for revenge I see
i played him once and lost no I have no
special memory of that but still want to
get to an even score the the can destroy
probably get the chicken yes we get it
here at least I can make some quick
moves yeah they it's very popular
nowadays to play d3 in case of the cheek
or in early don't know why because it's
it's really very toothless and in other
line some I am I have some yeah I
understand why this early d3 is to avoid
the marshal and so on but here we really
have a mmm a case where this d3 d4 is
just it just losing and move basically
this especially I have gotten on the
board a number of times and black
iridium has good active play um to see
for immediately or it's not not clear
can also play this first so that night
h5 is not going to happen yeah this is a
typical move plate in one second and if
you think again you recognize that be to
now is hanging and cannot be defended
properly yeah it's not starting to to
give up pawns ok I can just take it
really
okay to f6 I guess so I don't want to
trade and allow Queen D for with the
tempo this kind of this kind of things
ok he clearly wants to play something
like night f-fire for something to to
irritate me get the night here to to get
in 95 it's about placed there anyway so
night 95 now I can also think of Bishop
g5 okay this looks like an easy easy
continuation activating the Queen as
well if he takes on c4 I'm take with the
pond and then I have firm I have them
the sea pond as a pass um okay Queenie
five or see you have queen e five looks
good with the tempo and then see three
groups e8 and I have learned a half also
the bishop here which is nice only six
at least that's far better piece then
then the night k Roxy HM looks normal ok
and then the seaborne can start them can
start a move
yeah do I want to take on a two or is
that something better and then see to
whom that's odd that actually quite good
yeah see to take see 290 20 and I
promote I'm meeting him I'm really
meeting him honey so I should take it
from me he has 92 though to try to
defend hmm
this will indeed indeed seed save him
for the moment 92 we'll get it back hmm
some other move mania
yeah okay come on it's it's okay it's
really okay 92 I can just play this play
this position I wonder now maybe this
one now if I've yes the ape on the apron
is some in connection with the the
bishop is very nice to have so just a
form can give this check on the aid
that's probably in probably still right
take this it's probably not enough f5 is
also possible that this weakens the
whole the whole lung structure quite
considerably
not so easy to support them to support
the neue dad's spot the pond time
warning yeah it's it's difficult to play
this for win with with this 50 seconds
okay i'm going to try no you does not
have f3 sg3 is just hang
if a jack can I overlooked a number of
things here
yeah I am The Queen of the Night on the
open board in 30 seconds him yeah of
course you can just hope for blonde am
now it's very difficult to play check
check mmm yeah no I think I'm really
winning this check at least in eyes got
this chick hmm ok no he's good Queen f8
all kinds of stuff check
check check now night so 5 of course
check yeah does not see it of course he
just wants to win on time Jack does not
look for any good moves check check
check check check
white forfeits on time um yeah okay yeah
of course I had a hard time yen this in
this position fi this is the right move
it's winning but it's very difficult to
do because you you really have no worm
you have no time and the king is wide
open now and this is much better by the
way ah this is bad yeah why don't I see
this move it so easy and the a pawn is
promoting yeah not in good shape i guess
this is this is very easy yeah queen bee
to know it's clear that this this end
game is almost almost winning with the a
pawn I just need to trade Queens for
example but he M not easy to do and
after this the counter play against my
king becomes becomes very very critical
gee dumb it's very easy to lose even
because because of that yeah this is now
at least for the computer win but
playing this with 20 seconds is a
different matter check check I think I
did a decent job until up and to the
point where we're blunder shall still a
win yeah this right need to need to move
quick Queenie for is winning out and now
I need to go to g6 and not here of
course we're not see five wins but here
I am here yes no check and this is the
end of it I have the the main thread
yeah okay yeah only wants to win on time
he does not look for good moves check so
check here i'm jang i'm winning again
check scaping luther king check check
you know yeah I can take the queen but I
have four seconds so um yeah and here I
even one on time with with pre moves
yeah okay well we did it's it's a note
it's an old old argument it's simply
that those games get far more logical at
the end when you at least have a second
increment on your hand and not not this
the main point though is I should really
play Queen B to hear it's not either not
difficult to see but yeah I only saw
this F 5 which is very risky alright
thanks for watching